hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll back in the early 1990s there
was an idea going around called the end
of history the Berlin Wall had fallen
the USSR was dissolving there was a
feeling that history had been very
interesting you know thousands of years
of conflict in war and trying out
different forms of government and
society but that now as the 20th century
came to a close we had more or less
figured it out the way to live is in a
liberal democracy and liberal democracy
was gaining ascendance throughout the
world even old dictatorships or
authoritarian regimes were crumbling
under the democratic pressures as it
turns out the idea of democracy is not
necessarily a stable one you can have a
democratic society that gets rid of its
democratic institutions for one reason
or another and a couple of centuries
which is the time period over which
democracy has been ascendant in the
Western world is a short period
historically right now we're in a period
where the world is changing rapidly in
many ways and you can't just say
everything is done politically we
figured it out we're all gonna be
Liberal Democrats going forward indeed
as many of you might have noticed just
over the past couple of years there has
been increasing anti-democratic
sentiment around the world it can be
very blatant in some places some
countries have elected through
democratic means quite explicitly
anti-democratic leaders here in the
United States there's certainly been
controversies and arguments about
whether or not our new Trump
administration is not getting in line
with the norms of liberal democracy
attacking the media undercutting our
confidence in our electoral processes
and so forth around the world strongmen
and autocratic forces are ascendant and
you can have different opinions about
this you can think that this is a real
problem and if you do think it's a real
problem then I think that it's something
that is not just alarmism I think that
if you are of the opinion that this is
happening and this is bad
there's more than enough evidence that
we should really take the
seriously you might on the other hand
think this is just liberals complaining
that they lost the election they're not
used to having a strong leader they have
to fight against and if that's true ok
but it's up to you to articulate exactly
why it's okay to attack the media in
certain ways what should be the norms
that are always respected no matter who
is the boss no matter which party is in
power this is not an easy thing to do
so it's important that we think about
these things and today's guest is Yasha
monk who is one of the most interesting
and articulate people who is thinking
seriously and carefully about these
issues right now
dr. monk is a lecturer on government at
Harvard University he's also a senior
fellow in the political reform program
at new America and he's also the
executive director at the Tony Blair
Institute for Global Change in his spare
time apparently he writes a weekly
column at Slate online and he also hosts
a podcast of his own over there called
the good fight his most recent book is
the People vs democracy why our freedom
is in danger and how to save it I
strongly recommend reading this book
it's an eye-opener it can be depressing
if you take it seriously and if you
don't take it seriously if you don't
disagree with it and as I said it's
important to explicitly say and as
reasonable calm and persuasive ways you
can why we shouldn't be worried about
these things one way or another this is
something we all have to be thinking
about so let's go
[Music]
Jasha monk welcome to the mindscape
podcast my pleasure
so I'll start with a little preamble
here because I'll admit on the one hand
I'm very excited to have you on the
podcast both because I've loved your
work on Twitter and in other places
since I discovered it and also because
you're a fellow podcaster you're the
first guest I've had who is an expert on
being on both sides of this microphone
professional and I'm gonna judge you on
every transgression I know well I know
that yes that's well I'm looking forward
to I want the report card after it's all
said and done but there's also
trepidation because it's politics and
even if it's political science and
intellectual scholarship and so forth
there is the nitty gritty ugly tribalism
of politics and what I'm trying to get
around in this podcast is exactly that
trying to aim for the underlying ideas
the big picture so there is a big
picture that there certainly we all know
here in the United States there's
certain political things going on but
it's not just a random particular event
there are some trends underlying what's
going on here in the US and it's going
on more broadly right the world is
seeing at least it seems from the news
an upsurge in a kind of populist
nativist nationalist isolationist
authoritarian moment so just like to
start out why don't we we let's let's
imagine that over the next hour we'll be
digging in to some of the underlying
reasons why that's happening but what's
your take right now on sort of the state
of the world when it comes to this kind
of movement going on what I'm pretty
worried about what's going on in the
world I was just writing an article
where I started outlining how different
some countries in the world looked three
years ago you know three years ago The
Huffington Post had just announced two
great hilarity but it would cover the
presidential campaign by one journal
Donald J Trump in the entertainment
section written you had you know not
somebody a person you would avert a for
but you know a reasonable moderate
center-right a minister and David
Cameron
you know the idea of brexit was being
pursued by the UK Independence Party and
a few hardliners in matauri party but it
really seemed very unlikely it was a
leadership election and the Labour Party
which you know seemed to probably go to
every sensible person in Germany Angela
Merkel was at the height of her
popularity and you know that there
wasn't any far-right populist party in
in the parliament now you know today you
are seeing not just for a time populist
in power in the United States with
Donald Trump in places like the
Philippines with rigidity in Poland
Hungary and Italy in a whole bunch of
other places even in the countries that
are supposedly walking relatively well
and what countries were poppers have not
had taken over you have seen these
radical transformations of a political
system so today in Germany the
alternative for Germany which is quite
extreme he's in the Bundestag and
according to some polls it is now the
second biggest party in the country
larger than the Social Democrats in
Great Britain you now have a leader of
Labor Party who bears more resemblance
to Jill Stein than he does to Bernie
Sanders you have a prime minister who is
embattled from the far right of her own
party may lose her job any moment now
and you've had two years of the
establishment trying to figure out what
on earth to do about the populations
vote to brexit and not really making any
progress in figuring out what the plan
for the country so just as a snapshot of
some of the changes in the world I would
say doesn't look too good and fairly
recently I mean that that the picture
you paint is one of rapid change which
might even be extra worrying right yeah
absolutely so it comes on the heels of a
long development when you look at the
rise of populist parties and movements
it started in in you know at least be a
2002 little even earlier than that and
has been rising since so some 18 years
ago the average virtue of a populist
party in continental Europe for example
was about 7%
now it is more like 27 or 28 percent at
the very rapid increase
Shivam now being in power in a whole set
of countries you can drive from north to
south of europe without ever leaving a
country ruled by pockets that certainly
wasn't possible 10 or 15 years ago and
it's become particularly fast in the
last few years in part because what pop
lists are now at levels of strength
where they can suddenly form a
government I mean as a physicist do you
think about those kinds of things over
time I measured which is to say you have
systems that seem relatively stable and
we start seeing a certain kind of change
in them but it doesn't seem to worrying
people to notice it too much because the
system on the whole is still stable and
then eventually as it comes close to a
certain kind of threshold you see that
this morning please has much bigger
systemic effects and I think that's the
kind of moment we're now in with
populism yeah that's exactly right did
the idea of a phase transition where
things can be more or less on
appearances fairly stable over long
periods of time then suddenly something
happens my wife Jennifer would let who
is a science writer is actually working
on a book on this very topic exploring
the fact that while things can seem to
not be changing to our most direct
observations things can be changing
underneath the surface that secretly
lead up to these apparently radical
quick transformations and they can be
good you know public opinion switched
about gay marriage here in the United
States very quickly but secretly it was
being uh it was changing all along and
it can be for the bad just as well well
I hope she's gonna add a topic about the
cheering oh yeah well so that's that's a
good point because I want to dig in a
little bit deeper here what what is a
definition of populism when I was a kid
and I heard the word it made no sense to
me like populism means you're popular
and if you're in a democracy you should
be popular to be elected but of course
it means something a little bit
different than that
yeah and you know I mean I think that is
a real problem with that word on many
public appearances where try to define
populism I try to explain to people what
I mean by it was the precise definition
of it is people then the questions in
the question session say well what's
wrong with popular ism a populism but
popular ISM you know should politicians
try to be popular
we should it's a normal part of politics
for politicians to say hey you know
people unhappy with the current crop of
politicians and I'm gonna point out the
ways in which they are imperfect and and
and and and and mistaken and I'm gonna
try and rile up a little bit of emotion
against them and say hey I'm standing
for all of us popular things but they
haven't actually thought about oh so
that's perfectly normal
what's different about populism is the
claim that the only real reason why we
have problems today is that the existing
political elite has dropped or
self-serving the claim that they alone
truly stand for the people but while
they are the voice of a people everybody
who disagrees with them is by nature of
that illegitimate because if I stand for
people and some disagrees with me or
when they I against the people um and
then it often goes together with you
know very large extreme promises so that
once populist on power and they can't
live up to those promises as our
president sometimes likes to say who
knew that things could be so complicated
health care could be so complicated I
think if he was a student in one of your
classes Sean he might upon seeing the F
on his midterm say who knew that
physically so complicated um yeah but
they don't want to actually admit that
they told lies and and and and made huge
outside promises they say well why
haven't I been able to deliver for you
because the opposition are traitors and
they're undermining me because the free
press are fake news and then you could
be ugly position because I because the
independent institutions like like
judges or the FBI are all biased against
me and they now need to have the
independence taken away that's why
something is this worry right and so is
I'm getting the impression that in some
sense populism is defined in our
position to this group of elites and
maybe that's an ill-defined group but
it's the populace versus these peep
who have the power and don't deserve it
and need to be brought under control is
that there yeah that's right and you
know that's again there's an element to
that but it's normal and democracy but
you say hey you know the people in power
right now I'm Trudy serving out his
interests and and and we need to correct
that but but but it goes together for
populist with a real lack of respect for
basic rules and norms of consent
so you know the thing was very shocking
in the United States in 2016 but a
presidential candidate would you know
leave in doubt whether he will accept
the outcome of election that he would
not just attack his opponent as having
the wrong ideas or perhaps even not
being as morally upright as he is um
better saying I'm gonna lock up right
those things that they do but and
willingness to accept the kinds of rules
we need not because they're important in
themselves or because we somehow have a
weird attachment to norms but because in
order for democracy to work I need to
not only be able to elect the guy I won
today I also need to be sure but he's
gonna respect the rules and constraints
of his power enough so that I have a
chance of electing somebody else four
years from now and in many countries
that doesn't have yeah I've always
thought that the real birth of a
democracy is the first time that the
party in power faces an election and
loses and hands it over right and so you
can win an election that's great but we
assume it's part of you know having
norms and so forth and we'll probably
get into that but we assume that there
are rules that everyone agrees to play
by and certainly in addition to
attacking the media a attacking the
legitimacy of elections is unfortunately
common these days yeah no that's that's
that's exactly right you know the real
test of democracy is whether politicians
are willing to cede power when they lose
and you know in many cases we haven't
yet seen the test for populist in part
because and this is another test they
have skewed for playing field so much
that the opposition doesn't have a real
chance of money so what we're seeing
increasingly is that you don't have our
political systems in which you know
somebody says hey I'm dictator now
there's never gonna be an election again
countries like Russia like Venezuela
have elections yeah there are elections
in which some of the most promising
candidates of your position aren't
allowed to run in which we might even be
put in jail in which if you go to a
protest or rally for the opposition
candidate you might be beaten up by the
police or you might be locked away all
of the main television channels are
under control of the regime or of close
allies of it you have changes to the
electoral system that are meant to favor
the governing party and you take all of
those things together and you basically
have managed elections in which people
can go out to vote but the opposition
doesn't have a fair shot at victory and
so what we're seeing in places like
Hungary is that the countries are
rapidly moving towards such a system and
even if despite all of us obstacles your
position should somehow win I have real
questions in my mind
about whether a victor are one for
example would voluntarily step down from
power well it's always been in physics
terms as we were talking about before
there's always been an instability in
the very idea of democracy if you're a
dictatorship and you know you just keep
the squeeze of power carefully enough
you can go on forever in a democracy
there's always the worry that the people
will democratically elect
anti-democratic rulers and that's an
instability if everyone chooses to be
non democratic then democracy can't
survive it's sort of the political
science equivalent of karl popper's
question about tolerance tolerating the
intolerant can be a bad thing
so these societies that are democratic
base base their success on the idea that
people buy into the idea of being
democratic which is not just voting for
the person you want but giving up power
when you don't
are we seeing the people in these
countries become less willing to give up
power when they lose um right-oh to to
the people I think are more willing and
tempted to vote for politicians who give
good science of not respecting the
limits on their power which is one of
the reasons why the title of my book is
the People vs democracy right it
captures that otherwise paradoxical idea
that people vote for a candidate who
says hey you know what
just trust me leave me to overpower
things are gonna work out somehow by the
way that sound you may hear in the
background I believe is Donald Trump
flying into London overhead so so you
know leave leave it to me I'll fix it
just give me a little bit more power um
trust me right but that base got to use
that power precisely in order to make it
impossible to displace a democratically
elected president or prime minister by
Democratic means by the way if you want
to hear about the scientists ideas of a
flaws of democracy or how a good story
for you oh yes please tell me the good
science story so I not remember the
details here and I'm a butcher and even
embellish a little bit in the process
but it was a great story I came across
about a year ago of quarter --dl the
great logician wanting to take his
citizenship so he had come to the United
States freeing the Nazis he was
convinced and one of his best buddies
with our Einstein who was also there at
the same time and you know he was
becoming eligible for citizenship and he
had to take first came to iron friend
who had already gone through the process
and said what what should I do to study
for this exam and I'm sure and said well
look you know they send you leaflets
just reach relieved that you'll be fine
but there was not one to take this kind
of thing without the requisite
seriousness and star gesturing stir up
trouble yeah exactly
started to you know really study up very
deeply on the Constitution and and the
separation of powers and how it all
works
and on the day of the exam
Einstein decided to to go to the test
with girdle as moral support for he
seems to be a little bit of a jackass
because on the on the on the road trip
over he started a skittle bell are you
sure that you really have prepared well
enough for this exam and so little comes
in a little bit of a bump of nerves and
recognizing Einstein they asked both of
them into an office and Einstein is
allowed to sit there as a process
administered and you know the the
official sort of as a liberal makes a
little small talk of curdle and says
riot you know I see you come from
Austria you know horrible what's what's
what's been happening there
okay says yes terrible what's happening
my country's tournaments as well you
know thankfully now in the United States
something like that could never happen
here as I say well actually I have been
studying the Constitution and there's a
deep floor and takes him under the table
with a shudder and he just answers a
couple of questioning it being
completely truthful is not always the
best strategy in the in these situations
I wonder if girdle was in fact just
thinking of the fact that you could vote
you that the Constitution allows itself
to be changed you can change it to be
anything you want and so which brings us
to another thing in your book I would go
further than that which is it's not just
if the Constitution can be changed which
by the way is very difficult to me that
but instead ultimately people have to
stand up wins but if you have a
president who does not respect the
rightful limits of his authority and he
controls a political party which also
happens to have a majority in Congress
and which also happens to have judges in
the Supreme Court whose loyalty to a
particular ideological movement those
more deeply than their loyalty to
constitutional values and values of
their institution
um then they can in practice get away of
all kinds of things that might in fury
not be allowed and that is ultimately
what dangers always be that political
forces take over system and we simply do
things that on a fair reading of the
local constitution they shouldn't be
allowed to do but because there are the
people who are actually in in the
offices of institutions that are meant
to stop them don't do the job have a
higher loyalty to a party or man when
the Constitution they get away of doing
it himself so perhaps that's what good
was thinking sadly um the record of
office story does not explain what the
little extra fourth row whatsoever so
there could be all sorts of flaws that
we don't need that we don't even see but
but yeah maybe a flaw that only Gerda
was brilliant enough back seat you're
putting your finger on you know the role
of buy-in to the democratic process to
the norms that we have and one of the
big things that has been highlighted in
the recent years since Trump has been
elected is the extent to which we do
rely on people behaving well not simply
[Music]
following the law as it is written but
following the spirit of the law in some
sense as well and so is this another new
thing or is this just something that
they were less artful about taking
advantage of before it seems to me that
in the past there was less political
polarization at least here in the US and
there is more belief in the standards of
you should do the right thing even if it
doesn't benefit your party I've been
recently rewatching the West Wing and
there's an you know an episode where a
Republican Committee Chairman stops one
of the people on his committee from
questioning a democratic witness because
it wasn't on the topic that they were
supposed to be investigating even though
it would have been devastating to the
Democratic Party for them to do that and
we're sitting there thinking there's
just no way that that would happen right
now if you can take the advantage you
would just win so it does seem like
something has really changed well
there's lots of things that happen to
West Wing that never happened in real
life one of which is that people always
have the perfect retort
no it's the world if everybody had two
hours to think of the next move but but
no I think there is a real
transformation there which is caused by
a whole set of things one of them is
rising polarization um the public as a
whole United States is not necessarily
more extreme the political cues from a
polarized now than they were twenty or
forty or sixty years ago the political
parties are so the most moderate
Democrat used to be far to some
conservative than the most moderate
Republican that is no longer the case is
a real gulf between them and we also see
by the way many people just having less
of an understanding of the Constitution
I think for a long time there was a very
deep commitment to the idea of having to
transmit political values from one
generation to the next the idea of a
founding fathers of how important it is
to have it constitutional culture and I
think because we started to take our
democracy for granted with slightly tug
so the education for granted and we know
from various studies with people know
much much less now there's basic aspects
of a constitution the kinds of things
you need to pass the citizenship test
how many Supreme Court justices are
there and so on then they did a few
decades ago um I also think that is a
strange element of a useful fiction
having been exposed I mean even two or
three years ago when you go back through
what some of the most intelligent
commentators were writing and I didn't
agree with me at the time but they were
you know some of the smartest people
writing about is making forceful
arguments they said look Sammy that
Donald Trump at a ceiling of how much
support somebody can get like that can
get you know people have this deep
commitment to the Constitution to these
norms if somebody says these kinds of
outrageous things to tell these kinds of
lies
most people are just going to be so
turned off by them that they gonna run
away from it and and now we seem that's
not the case and that encourages more
and more people to act in the same way
because apparently all of those things
that we thought we would be he'd be
punished for we're not punished for
right it's like you
now you have an electric fence that pass
your your road to you know the
supermarket and you always sort of walk
around it and one day you know by
mistake you touch it and you realize
well you know what actually I didn't get
a shock from it this time so that's what
I get tomorrow and once you've done that
seven to eight times you know there's no
longer cost in your mind - touching
electric fence because perhaps bones
never across to it but now we know yeah
one of the great things in your book is
that you closely analyzed the phrase
liberal democracy I think a lot of
people will just sort of blurt that out
as if it's one thing but there are two
words they're liberal and democracy and
you point out that they mean different
things and they're both under attack in
different ways all the ways that might
come together in some way so why don't
you help us understand that sure I'm the
first thing to say is that justice
populism isn't popular ism which which
seems obvious but it's important liberal
democracy is not the opposite of
conservative democracy right it's a
philosophical term in the sense in which
I use liberal you know Barack Obama was
as much of a liberal as you know as
joejoebee Bush or Ronald Reagan or Bill
Clinton they all had a basic commitment
to those values oh so we use this term
liberal democracy and we don't often
think about what it means and and how it
is for those two elements but liberal
element I'm a democratic element may
actually be in tension with each other
so wait I understand that our political
system has these two fundamental goals
the first is to allow individual liberty
that's the liberal element number 2 you
write classical realism yeah well a
classical rhythm has certain
connotations that I'm about economic
policy for example which aren't
necessarily entail but it is a set of
freedoms that individuals enjoy um so
that means that I can say what I want I
can workship as I want or not worship I
can be in whatever relationship I want
to be up in a relationship um and and
nobody gets to call me and in order to
sustain that I need both things like
freedom of speech and we need to have
of powers because if the president
dislikes what I say he can't be capable
of just throwing me in prison we need
independent institutions to do
prosecution but so that offending
somebody political power can be
dangerous too so that's the first
element and the second element is where
to be straightforward especially once
you've saturated liberal element out
it's a democratic element it's bad well
you actually need to be able to
translate popular views into public
policies democracy is the rule of the
demos rule over people so actually what
happens politically needs to be
dependent on what we as individuals want
rather than being determined by a king
or a dictator or priest or an imam or a
jungle my fear is that these two
constitutive elements of our political
system are coming apart more and more
but for a long time we've had political
systems but I've been reasonably good
with some of these shortcomings about
respecting and protecting individual
rights but they haven't done a terribly
good job of actually being responsive
and now what we're getting is the
political system in which yes a decent
first some popular views are being
translated into public policy but it is
at the price of individual rights of the
rights of minorities and increasingly
other kinds of separation of powers that
we need to sustain in order for the
system to be stable over time well this
this brings up yeah so there's two
directions to go here let's go on both
of them but first in some sense you're
suggesting that there are the countries
or super country kind of organizations
like the European Union that are in fact
anti-democratic that they are doing
things behind the scenes that it's even
in the United States where we still have
elections there's so much of everyday
governmental activity that is done by
you know executive departments people
who are not elected but have an enormous
power over people's lives
there is sort of a legitimate complaint
that people have that their views are
not being put into public policy there's
this whole invisible structure that is
making things happen and so in some
sense that's a fair critique of the
current system is that right um yeah I
mean I think I wouldn't go so far as to
say that is anti-democratic which sort
of implies a conspiracy against the
people or conspiracy against democracy I
think it's a little less exciting than
that and so it's a undemocratic who
sounds similar but it is different an
important aspect is that it's often a
response to quite real requirements so
our economy has become much more complex
the needs of Public Policy have become
more complicated in part because we need
much more international cooperation
because it's harder to govern the
economy and so what we've seen over the
last you know 50 or 60 years and in
virtually every country is the rise of a
set of institutions that do constrain
popular will in complicated ways so on
the one hand you just have Parliament's
congressmen and states not being
responsive enough to what people want
because for rising role of money in
politics revolving door between
lobbyists and legislators and all those
kinds of things and on the other hand we
have in a variety of independent
agencies like the Environmental
Protection Agency or Consumer Protection
Bureau we have a central bank let's both
much more powerful and and certain ways
more dependent than used we have a huge
expansion of judicial review and the
growing importance and and criticized
ation of the supreme court we have
international trade treaties lots of
international agencies to deal with all
kinds of issues and you know these
things aren't a conspiracy against four
people they are often you know
responding to the fact for example that
it's really hard to figure out how to
keep the power plant safe and that you
need lots of experts to make the
decision and having Congress version it
day in day out probably doesn't make a
lot of sense so why don't we create an
agency that can pass a lot of those
involves regulations and Congress has
the authority to abolish with agency but
well there's there's a real logic behind
this but cumulatively it does raise the
danger that people look at what's going
on and say you know what for most of his
stuff
I'm never consulted I didn't even
understand what it really means Congress
certainly is making those decisions so
how is this video democracy yeah I think
I mean this is I think it's dawning on
me during this conversation I think is a
very very important point that even
putting aside all the questions about
nativism and racism and immigration and
so forth there is a thing that is going
on that is purely based on the fact that
the world is becoming more complicated
and more interconnected technology is
advancing you know we see this in purely
technological realms where there are
computer programs that do really really
important functions in the world that
nobody understands right no one person
it knows what's going on inside that
computer program and the same thing is
true about government nobody understands
everything that's going on and maybe you
could imagine a nightmare scenario where
two things happen simultaneously one is
that people become frustrated that their
needs are not being met that they're not
getting ahead that they see the
government is sort of big and invisible
and elitist and unresponsive and they
vote populist sin2 powered as a response
to that and at the same time all this
complication gives more ways for the
people who are really up in the game
people who are powerful and wealthy and
connected to take advantage of it and to
increase their own wealth so we see this
combination of populism and growing
inequality and we say that out loud
that's a plausible picture of what we're
faced with right now yeah absolutely and
and and and this particular aspect of it
I have to say is for one but I find it
most difficult get my head around
because the other stuff is really
worrying and scary but I sort of know in
theory at least what to do in response
right so you know the fact that money
plays far too big a role in our politics
um look that's terrible and given that
the Supreme Court is likely to be
dominated by people who don't see that
as a problem
foreseeable future it is in practice
hard to know how to fight it but in
theory I sort of know what to do right
we need much more robust and plain
finance regulations make it harder for
people you know to go from Congress to
Wall Street and so on and so forth right
oh I don't know what the solutions are
even foe I struggle to to imagine a
power which we would implement um on
this other end it is it is harder
because I really do think the two values
are in conflict with each other here and
one of those values is responding to
popular will and having a sense with
this real democratic accountability and
the other is actually achieving the
expertise in the coordination we need in
order to solve very real problems for
people gonna be pissed off if we don't
solve so let's take you know the topic
of climate change you know in order to
deal with climate change adequately we
need to have you know nearly 200
countries around the world coordinated
if United States does a lot of effort to
reduce its carbon emissions but you know
Russia and China don't at all which is
not gonna be able to deal with a problem
but how on earth are we going to
structure a decision-making process in
which we coordinate the actions of 200
countries and yet ordinary citizens if
you like yeah you know what I already
had the same heads going to be
incredibly hot yeah and the timescale
for human beings to care about what
happens in the world is not much longer
than a human generation or a human
lifetime so that's that that's gonna be
a very difficult problem in the best of
times but then we also have in addition
to technology and globalization and
connectivity and complexity we also do
have the questions of diversity and
immigration and so forth and they're
clearly these play a role you know in
the aftermath of Trump's election there
was a debate is it are people voting for
him because of economic anxiety or
because of racism or nativism and
clearly they both play some kind of role
but you had it aligned in your book
which I thought was very provocative you
say neither in North America nor in
Western Europe has there ever been a
truly equal multi-ethnic democracy so
what we're trying to create right now is
a historically unique experiment is it
plausible even if slightly depressing to
think that one of the reasons why
democracy has been relatively successful
over the past couple centuries is
because it's been kind of a very special
kind of democracy where there was always
one group that was in charge and
therefore didn't feel threatened and the
attempt to really be democratic not only
among people but among different kinds
of people and different groups is much
less stable and harder to maintain
that's a fear
I mean one of the striking things about
our political history you know well
beyond but well before the the prime of
a democratic age is that those states
that were reasonably democratic tended
to be more homogeneous that when you
think of you know the examples of a
Fryderyk multi-ethnic state or city
before say you know 1900 we might think
of Vienna in the 19th century we might
think of Istanbul or Baghdad at various
points in the Middle Ages you might
think of Rome in a 2nd or 3rd century
but those were usually when these places
either went democratic or at least women
artists didn't really have voting rights
um and in a way that's obvious when you
think about it because it's easier for
me to tolerate somebody who might have a
slightly different culture from me a
different religion who perhaps if it is
difficult
origin if I don't feel like they have a
voice of my political fate know I don't
have any power he doesn't have any power
over decisions are made by the monarch
anyway so all right invasion fun I look
at people who are quite different from
me and say oh these people actually can
go and vote and effect what happens to
me it becomes harder so so that's one
historical worry but I have and when you
see how deep resentment is especially
and thus increasing good social science
from this of people who used to be
dominant
and now threaten the dominance and you
know in in Europe the idea of what it
was to be Italian or French or German
was always pretty deeply mono-ethnic and
monocultural is somebody who's descended
from a particular ethnic stock and so
suddenly these societies are asked to
say oh hey you know what somebody who
comes from other parts of the world even
got born here but her parents did they
can be a member of our society to invest
real resistance against that and the
States and in Canada this was being a
multi-ethnic Society but there's been
one is a point out with a very deep
racial and religious hierarchy and which
members of a particular group had big
advantages over others and so again um
you know the people who are having some
of those and earned privileges taken
away are going to be quite resentful
about that now I don't condone that I
all have a right to those privileges but
I think it's actually important to take
a moment to try and understand sort of
where that sentiment comes from and I
was picture sort of you know somebody
who's not perhaps especially talented
not especially good-looking not
especially affluent and you know in
Italy in 1970 they might have said you
know what man I get most social respect
and all of that but at least I am
Italian rather than Albanian and at
least I'm part of a majority population
rather than one of us Moroccan
immigrants
well now suddenly you know the kid over
Slovenian immigrants might be making
more money than you he might be your
boss he might be standing in power and I
celebrate that as as as political
progress um but it isn't too surprising
that people who have that status
advantage taken away from them you can
no longer say hey just by virtue of
being a member of this group I have a
certain kind of social status but
superior that they're gonna be resentful
for having been taken away from there
there was a sociologist who did a study
that I thought I read back a couple
years ago out to look her up I forget
her name but you know it was one of
these things she's ahead of the curve in
terms
of asking the question what did the
Trump voters really want and she
embedded herself she was a Berkeley
leftist progressive that's just he went
to like you know I think your finger
fiery hot chop oh probably yes exactly
and just talk to people and sort of you
know lived their lives and and got to
know where they were and she came up
with this metaphor and she then read the
metaphor back to them and they said yes
that's exactly it and the metaphor was
you know you think of yourself as you
know standing in line in the race to
life you know and there's better times
ahead and you're walking toward them
slowly you're doing your work and it's
effort but you're making progress
and then you see off to the side you
know a whole bunch of new people
skipping the line just being you know
elevated in front of you not waiting
their turn and this feels unfair to you
and these are you know immigrants or
minorities or gays or lesbians or
whatever or even women for that matter
and people said yes that's more or less
how they feel even if it's not really an
accurate representation so I mean I I
want to you know give value to that
feeling like how can we give people back
the feeling that they are in charge of
their destiny part this must have at
least some role to be played by
inequality and the fact that you know
more and more wealth is going to the
wealthier but still on a broader scale
we need to be able to make people think
that this is this is their country they
can get ahead it's their country as well
as other people's countries and that's a
good thing rather than a bad thing I'm
not quite sure how to get there in any
simple way yeah and here again I mean
you know the striking thing is that
we've never quite done that so so we
should be prepared for for some pain but
what you're describing is exactly right
we need to figure out how we can defend
minority groups against frankly the
quite obvious attacks of the suffering
at the moment and more broadly the
disadvantages that that they have
suffered for a long time and at the same
time we need to make sure that the
majority group isn't a short of having
special privileges I don't think we can
just the usual
but that they feel like you know they
are still going to get to the front of a
line at some point as well all right
that because if they have miss
presidents have a going to be fulfilled
and we don't see those is being
threatened by blurs broader cultural
demographic changes and and doing both
of those things at the same time is is
incredibly hard but but our ability to
Witten the kind of society we want is
dependent on that and I want to add
something here which is important which
is but I think sometimes I hear a lot of
impatience with that question uh from
people who perhaps are members of
minority groups are just more broadly
from from laughs um and I get that right
because you know here we are we are
already suffering from historical
discrimination with being attacked right
now and we're supposed to worry about
the feelings of those people who have it
better than us anyway I absolutely get
that react but I do think there's a
slight contradiction in how we sometimes
think about that which is that I keep
the same people say no we live in a
society in which racism and white
supremacy and structural and justice
those incredibly deep and you know the
majority group has these incredible
reserves of power and influence and so
on and at the same time we should not
give an inch to them we should be
absolutely uncompromising and I'm not
quite sure how we reconcile those two
things because if you really think for a
majority group as such the power and
influence then in order to affect any
kind of change you need to make your
case to them to some extent right yeah
you need then if you if you don't have
any some of them on board then you're
just gonna lose every time
right and so I think that the most
helpful way of doing this is to actually
appeal to the better instincts off
perhaps not every single member of a
majority group but but but the bathroom
majority and this is by the way with the
civil rights movement it it's in many
ways with Barack Obama did um and it can
be
but I'm sure it's frustrating I'm sure
it sometimes means that we can't be
quite as blunt at least in certain parts
of politics as would like to be not give
vent to our justified anger you know
quite as free Deus as we would like but
but if you actually care about making
this country better and winning those
political victories um I feel that it's
necessary to some extent yeah and I feel
you know it's easy for me to give advice
to people who are members of
historically discriminated against
groups since almost none of the groups
that I'm in have faced that but I also
think it's important to distinguish
between groups and individuals right and
I think the fact that there is white
privilege and male privilege and
cisgender privilege it said I think
these are very real things those don't
mean that even if you're a member of all
those groups your life was easy or you
haven't struggled I think there are real
struggles that people go through no
matter what groups they're members of in
some sense everyone struggles but there
are some you know poor people or people
who economics and politics have left
behind in a very real way and there's
nothing wrong with taking their concerns
seriously it's kind of crucially
important to the bigger Democratic
project well and right and I think
that's a real problem of distribution
here right which is to save it obviously
you know on average members of of
historical discriminated groups by
virtue of being members of historic
discriminated groups have faced many
more obstacles and many more struggles
than then the numbers for majority
groups and that is a deep injustice bed
as a society we need to reconcile but
obviously the kinds of people who end up
being the spokespeople
for that position also and the
spokespeople by coincidence Beswick
speak of they have had most success in
life and perhaps also had some
advantages relative to other members of
their own group and so you often end up
with dynamic in which people who
actually personally have also
discriminate experienced real
discrimination and so on that have gone
to some of the best colleges in the
country make six-figure salaries and so
on
sort of
you know simply explaining why it is
that that most perhaps all members of a
dominant group have issues privileges
and you end up people you know with
people who haven't had a great education
perhaps have had real personal tragedies
happening to them who perhaps have had
abused of parents or come from
households but a deeply dysfunctional so
listening to this and say oh you you
know professor so-and-so or fellow and
so-and-so institution or you know
columnist and so-and-so these people
magazine I explained to me why it is
that you're you know so disadvantaged
and and and and that's a real problem
dynamic right yeah which doesn't
invalidate the fact but of course there
are those underlying structural justices
embed but but but I think it means we
need to be a little sensitive of how to
communicate that in a way that people
are willing to to to have an open mind
yeah again I feel bad asking people who
are members of groups who have been
discriminated against to be patient and
understanding and empathetic to have
people who are members of groups who
have been dominating them for hundreds
of years but it's also a good strategy
long-term I think they I think there's a
place for bomb-throwing and you know
raising a ruckus there's also a place
for sitting down and reasoning together
and appreciate appreciating each other's
points of view becoming less and less
common and by was where I emphasize two
things a this is not a moral claim as a
strategic claim right um it's just a
claim about what to do in order to
ensure that people like Donald Trump
aren't in a position to do tremendous
damage and violence to us groups and be
I think you know we would do well not to
talk about you know how much of a
raucous should you raise and and how
loud you be about that I think to me
it's about the manner in which we talk
about it not how much we talk about it
or how passionately we talk about it
which is to say that at a moment in
which minorities aren't very well
attacked there's no limit to how much we
should talk about it I just think that
the
strategically productive way of talking
about it is to actually say this is the
kind of society we want and he is where
that society is one that should be
appealing to all American and why
despite the table jug chapters in
American history that she calls on the
best traditions in American history
Nicole's on the ideals of the founding
fathers even if the founding fathers
themselves we're in many ways four and
that's something that from you know
Martin Luther King to Barack Obama a lot
of people in in the history of our
country have have done incredibly
successfully um so so that to me you
know appears to be the way to actually
make make headway yeah and I'm gonna
choose to continue to be optimistic on
balance about the force of reason and
community and appealing to the better
angels of our nature however let me also
say that I read your book and it's very
depressing there's real prospects of
things going badly I don't be alarmist I
don't want to overreact is certainly in
my mind very possible that despite
everything Donald Trump in the United
States and other people in other
countries will be moments in history not
precursors of an entirely new phase of
history but there's also another
possibility that things go just
disastrously wrong you know if you asked
what would it like what would it be like
for a functioning healthy democratic
liberal democracy like the United States
to turn into an authoritarian
dictatorship
maybe the precursors would look more or
less like what we're seeing so how
seriously should we be worried about a
true collapse of liberal democracy in a
country like the United States uh well I
think you know there's a way of
interpreting a question purely about
probabilities and a way of interpreting
it about you know expected values which
is to say less you know I don't think
that the likelihood of liberal democracy
claps United States is only 50% it's
probably quite a bit lower than
but given how disasters that outcome
should be I think we should be very
worried about it
5% I don't know it's hard to put a
percentage around it but you know the
striking thing is for 5 or 10 years ago
local scientists thought that it was
essentially impossible but they're like
zero that once countries have changed
misses your point from earlier had
changed governments were free and fair
elections at least a couple of times
once we had a GDP per capita of more
than about $14,000 in today's terms they
were safe we really didn't have to worry
about them and we already seen in
countries like Hungary that that's
untrue that you have over town populace
take over there and in my mind destroy
liberal democracy for sure probably not
even because of a liberal democracy but
erect a form of competitive
authoritarianism and now we're seeing
the president United States take this
first steps that people like Putin and
Russia like erawan and Turkey that
Google Chavez in Venezuela have taken a
few years ago and because we are richer
country with country for more vibrant
civil society a very deep constitutional
tradition there's every hope that we're
going to be able to stop that
but in step three or step 4 Donald Trump
is not gonna be able perhaps not want to
take step five and six and seven as well
but certainly as a scholar of
comparative politics the pattern I'm
seeing the direction we going in is very
concerning indeed yes as a good Bayesian
I feel it's my responsibility
intellectually to actually assign
probabilities to everything that I think
might happen but I take your point which
is that we've definitely undergone a
change from thinking that that kind of
disaster in the United States is simply
inconceivable for all practical purposes
to at least thinking that it's
conceivable and if it is rare and it
doesn't happen then you know there's a
silver lining there that we take this
more seriously and hopefully we can fix
things down the road the pessimism that
I have about that is one of the many
ways I was wrong about politics over the
last
years was I dramatically underestimated
the extent to which serious grown-up
members of the Republican Party would
resist the worst impulses of a
trump-like administration and I take it
that that's also happening in other
countries there are you know you you
join a group you do game theory what is
best for my re-election chances that's
just way more important than what's best
for the larger country and that's even
more depressing than the fact that one
person or another wins an election to me
yeah that's what people's here the first
is that you know as a pokel scientists
have always been quite skeptical of some
of my colleagues who took a rational
choice approach too much of a political
world and and in particular to this case
right we said look I mean basically from
just think what maximizes the
politicians chance of reelection and
then from that very simple assumption
you can derive most of them yeah you
know I don't quite buy that if I'm a
complicated have some a more idealistic
than that well I've become much more
sympathetic to that approach over the
last couple of years I have to tell you
um the the other thing is that you know
I used to be the most pessimistic person
in the room I mean I'm a sort of
democracy dream hipster right I worried
about democracy before was cool
and I used to be called a Cassandra a
lot of the time as a result and I always
want to say be people but Cassandra was
right damn it read the story um I didn't
made me sound like much of a Hank but um
fit but you know I was the pessimist in
debates about what would happen to the
Republican Party once Donald Trump won
the presidency you know I fought you
know the optimist Ford you know what we
as people have very different beliefs
from Baraka from from from Donald Trump
and they have deep commitment to
constitutional values and so they're
just gonna rain him it I what no that's
not true
the day is actually of trumpet was point
and you know a couple of them might flip
and and over taught over time Donald
Trump is going to succeed in replacing
the party with his own base he's gonna
have Trump as candidates running the
primary and there'll be a sort of
Republican civil war for four or six or
eight years but eventually it'll turn
well it turns out speaking of you know
having to update your probabilities they
were both wrong but what happened is
much more extreme than what I predicted
and that's that Republicans just flipped
they said you know what Trump is so
popular this is clearly where we at now
even though for many years I talked
about values that um you know they they
different I'm just going to go over this
now and so much more quickly much more
formally than pessimists like me had
predicted
Trump has wound up being in control of
Republican Party and as Asians I think
we should therefore also update our
probability of similar shifts happening
in other institutions I'm much more
worried now when I was six or seven
months ago about the Supreme Court
acquiescing with extreme behavior by
Donald Trump yeah and the evidence is
there all right so we collect more data
we update our priors and
that's not the it's not good news for
optimism but there's still there's still
some remaining let me just play the
devil's advocate here part of the
pessimism that I have is that I know
some pretty smart people in academia and
elsewhere who are saying you know like
sure Donald Trump is not you know gonna
win any IQ tests but if we look
worldwide if we look not just at Europe
but if you look at China or Russia isn't
it possible that there's a sense in
which a strong even strong man
government gets more done I mean
especially looking at China there are
people who say you know well sure it's
not a democracy human rights are not
good but boy they can really build
bridges really really well isn't there a
trade-off there that we might think
about buying into and what do you say to
that argument well if you think Simon
festival view of retirement systems that
work very well actually very limited in
number um in China does work visa
bollocks
before now there's a real question about
whether it can transition from being a
mid income economy to a high income
economy but is very difficult to emulate
China I like to quip that you know China
works very well in practice but it's a
mess in few you know it has a very
unique history um that unless you happen
to have a communist party kicking around
it's been around for 60 years and still
sort of claims to be Maoist but actually
a state capitalist it's very difficult
to know how you would even go about
Emily
no not looking for countries which
resemble Donald Trump it's looking for
countries in which were a town populous
have taken over countries like Venezuela
countries like Turkey in Russia and
Hungary and they are not doing
particularly well economic right they
are deeply corrupt recipe erawan just
made his son-in-law the new finance
minister that would never happen here
that's okay unimaginable do we even know
who trumps an annoyance never heard of
the guy yeah behind the scenes and this
is by the way something when I talk to
members of a business community I do
emphasize to the moment you've already
seen companies like AT&T a essentially
bribes to Michael Cohen Trump's personal
lawyer you have seen attacks on American
companies for business decisions they
took like harley-davidson threatening
tax retaliation and so on rule of law is
one of the reasons why the American
economy has worked it try to be well you
don't want a situation in which your
successes businessman depends on whether
or not you in favor will the regime and
that's what natural thought that is how
business runs in many countries in the
world and those countries tend to have
much lower growth rates okay good this
is this big great to close I will play
the role of the genie coming out of the
bottle and I would give you one wish but
I'm only gonna give you a menu you don't
get to make up your wish and your way
exactly it's a multiple choice genie and
so here your choice is with the goal in
mind of you know some combination of
making the country more pluralistic and
liberal democracy successful
one option is you could radically
improve our educational system secondary
and primary you could really inculcate
values you can you know teach kids that
diversity is important and the
Constitution is important a rule of law
is important democracy and all that
stuff that's one option another is you
could really impose policies that would
help fight inequality
you know redistribute some of the wealth
not by you know necessarily socializing
everything but just a real tax code that
took capital gains and wealth into
account and really helped people maybe a
basic income or something like that that
is the second option and the third
option is we could make sure I don't
know how this would happen but we could
make sure the media actually told the
truth we could have you know different
voices in the media but make sure that
there was not any sort of state quasi
state-sponsored
propaganda machine that gave people the
news that they thought that they should
be hearing so those are your three
choices which one of those what do you
think is the most important I'm gonna be
very annoying here and literalist
natural scientists perhaps even if I may
be so bored answer everything a lot of
the things you're describing are
different parts of metal equilibrium and
it's very hard to change one of those
who are changing the other so I think if
you had much more economic equality you
also would have a much better education
system right and if people are better
educated then they would also you know
be less likely to watch Fox News and so
you know I think that that these things
go together for together also there's no
such thing as genies so you could have
said that that would have been an
adequate natural to scientific
opportunity all right you have to thanks
so much even if it's not always making
us more optimistic I think it is
important to understand what's going on
that's what really gives me optimism
that there are people like you that are
really taking these things seriously
looking at them as carefully and
rationally as we can in try
find a good way forward and there are if
I'm allowed a closing word that's things
that people can do I'm the people who
are listening to this podcast you can
you know if you have an answer to
Shawn's action question about you know
whether it's a B or C then go and work
at that if you think it's a go and work
at improving the educational system if
it's B then go and fight for more
incoming call if you think it see you
then go and found you and media company
or do whatever it takes but but you know
I I am worried about the future but I'm
not fatalistic because I do think it's
subject to human agency Anna like the
citizens of China and North Korea and
Turkey and Russia
Ouiser will still have the Liberty to go
and fight for our political values so
that's what our job is now good you you
correctly perceive with subtext of the
question all right
Jasha monk thank you so much for being
on the podcast thank you this is great
fun Thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]